uh
thank you for that introduction um it's
really nice to be back at at stanford
um some of you will know i i spent a
very happy year here
on sabbatical um um
i guess about seven years ago because i
think i'm due for another spectacle
uh um this is i think is my my third
uh opportunity to talk in the in the hci
seminar i think it was 11 years between
my first two and then
seven between these so i'm i'm like i'm
speeding up um
so yeah so this this talk that i want to
um the material i want to present today
is based on
a long-term study that we've be that
i've been doing along with some
colleagues uh of
of which started off as a study of
collaborative practice
in deep space science and has evolved in
a variety of a variety of ways
when i first put a talk together around
this work
i wasn't writing it as an hci
talk um i'm going to try and present it
a little more as an hci talk today or
maybe perhaps
an hri talk like i think what we are
going to be talking about in here in a
strange kind of way
is um is human robot interaction
um where the robot happens to be a
spacecraft
around about a billion kilometers away
so i want to start off i should
start off by by acknowledging um some of
my collaborators being part of this
project
um so janet vertezi who's a sociologist
and
uh in the on the faculty at princeton
um and an sts scholar who also spent
some time with us at irvine
um has been uh one of the sort of has
been working on
aspects of this project with us uh from
for for many years now
uh marissa cohen who was until recently
my phd student
is now my postdoc and will soon be um
an assistant professor at the i.t
university in copenhagen
and melissa mismanian who is one of my
faculty colleagues at uc irvine
in the informatics department and is an
organizational scholar
um uh so so although i am the only
person here to present the talk this is
very much
um uh collaborative collaborative work
okay i better explain some of the
stranger
words in the title of my talk and
perhaps first and most importantly
try and think about what it is we mean
by socio by socio material
um there has been in the organizational
science literature over the last
five maybe 10 years an increasing
interest in questions of social
materiality
and if you like we could see this as
the latest in a sort of historical
progression
of ways of thinking about the
relationship between technology
and social practice technology and
social stuff
organizational life and so forth if you
look back at
early work in understanding what
happens around technology and what
people do with it that work is often
characterized by a fairly sort of naive
technological determinism
the idea that you know technology just
happens and then we all
adapt right you know that that bang
technology falls on us like a like a
meteor um and uh and somehow you know
there are ripple effects that change
society um
the next sort of historical period of
studies particularly sort of
organizational studies about technology
and organizational life
focused on sort of what were there
broadly what we might call social
constructionists
so they say actually you know technology
doesn't just happen to society we make
technology and it's society and social
structures
that provide us with an interpretive
framework for understanding what a
technology might be
for us and it's not purely about its
intrinsic properties
it's about how it gets used and as
we all go about organizational life
social life cultural life
we are creating meaning for the
for for the artifacts the technologies
for the things that we do the
things the things that are around us so
that seems like a um a slightly more
satisfying position than the
technological determinism it
gives us as human beings a little bit
more of a role
but in some ways it's sort of a swing of
the pendulum a little too far in the
other direction
which somehow or at least in its more um
in in some
forms seems to uh evacuate
the technology of any kind of intrinsic
properties we stop thinking about the
constraints of the technology because
it's somehow all socially constructed so
when people have over the last couple of
years
been arguing for a position on
technological
on social and cultural analysis of
technology that
take that that's broadly called social
material or social materiality
what they want to point to is the idea
that um that as things are social
they are also material that as
um as social factors shape our
experience
so too do the material physical
characteristics of technologies spaces
places
um the things the things that we use
and so we need perhaps a new kind of
theoretical frame a social material
frame
that avoids the excesses of either
technological determinism
or pure social constructionism and
steers a sort of middle path right so
there's been a bunch of work of that
sort
emerging over the last over the last
several years and that's sort of broadly
where i'm going to be positioning
positioning this talk
however
as that sort of social material agenda
has been has developed
it ha it's often
been formulated in terms of a problem of
identifying the locus of agency that is
where things happen and who does stuff
all right how that's the agency here for
social analysis is like you know
where is the where is the sort of social
motive force right who is an
agent who gets to act where does acting
happen
right and so so you know the even the
accounts of socio-materiality
which lie somehow halfway between a
world in which technology
is the thing that does things and the
social world is the thing that does
things
um even within this middle ground of
socio-materiality
there's still this question of like well
where you know the problem becomes where
do you locate the agency is it
like how do we find the balance point an
account that incorporates the social
incorporates the material and somehow
puts them
puts them together and so lots of people
um
and i'll get more to this at the end
later in the talk where we sort of lift
back up to the theory
um lots of people have tried to sort of
account for social materiality
in terms of this thing about well we
know that they're both important
but we need to find the balance point we
need to find where the problem
is of agency is it more on the material
side and is it more
is it more on the social side that's an
approach to socio-materiality
that somehow curiously at the same time
as it tries to put to the social and
material together
also i've got to argue like holds them
apart it makes them parallel it says
they're both important but somehow we've
got to find the place where
they touch but they're somehow
independent domains
and what we're going to try and argue
for in this talk
is an approach that tries to say well
you know we don't want to think about
them
as as parallel domains we want to think
about them as somehow
always deeply entangled that what we
call the social or what we call the
material
are like selective projections out of
this complicated tangled ball of stuff
social materials stuff and i want to
think about
how it is that they they come together
and that actually
creates the context for each other
that is it's the social that creates the
context for understanding what material
materiality might even be
and vice ver and vice versa this all
sounds horribly abstract it's going to
get a little more
ethnographic in a minute um
i'm trying to decide oh the the that's
trying to decide if i was still going to
use this slide i'm just like making
things up on the fly
um i'm going to come back yeah so i'm
going to say almost nothing about this
but the kind of lens we're trying to use
and this like the launching off point
for this is what
we've been thinking about as uh as um
the word
around the word reconfiguring
so we talk very easily perhaps even too
easily especially in technical circles
about reconfiguring things
about reconfiguring our technologies
about reconfiguring ourselves about
reconfiguring
our organizations um and certainly the
people that we've been working with
if ethnographically i'll tell you about
in a second
use the word reconfiguring a great deal
but we want to stop and think about
what might be implied by that word
reconfiguring and start
actually with the notion of figuring so
figuring is a notion that actually gets
used a lot in feminist science studies
and other kinds of
and similar sort of critical
perspectives on on science and
technology
to refer to the process of
producing represent or representing the
world
figuring it and putting it in a figure
putting it in numbers
putting it in some kind of
representational form
um creating a representation that
somehow abstracts from the world but but
and
and in abstracting from the world makes
sense of the world but also produces the
world that we experience because
as we craft that figure we also create a
sort of
lay a perceptual lens for ourselves that
begins to tell us about the world
so when i build a mathematical model of
the world that also then shapes how it
is i'm going to encounter that world
look at that world think about that
world and so forth so this notion of
figuring
has a bi-directionality to it that i
produce
a figure a graph a graphic a
representation an inscription
a numerical model or whatever it is um
and in doing it i also kind of like
begin to like line the world up in a
particular kind of way so i've got to be
unconscious
of the bi-directional power of that
figuring
by call when we turned figuring into
configuring
this is con in the sense of sort of
width right figuring with
i never actually get to just figure
things i don't get to produce figures
all on my own the world has to cooperate
the world has to fit in with my figure
so this process of figuring that i do is
actually one of engagement with the
world you've got to recognize
the connection to the world that's
implied by the production of the figure
and then by reconfiguring we mean that
you never get to do that just once but
it's an ongoing thing
i build a model of the world and then i
continually look at the world through
that model and i have to adjust the
model and i tweak it
and the world changes because of the
model and i have to do these things
again so it's never
finished because a model is out and a
representation is always incomplete
there's always more work to be doing so
when so so we found that the research
um you'll see when i get to the end like
to come back to this
but we actually you know when people
would start to talk about
reconfiguration
what we found really interesting sort of
analytically in that
are all three of these notions that is
bringing
the world into alignment with some kind
of
depiction of it that we can have
technological access to
doing that in a way that understands a
connection between
representational practice and the world
and doing it over and over and over and
over again
okay let's talk about the ethnography
and then perhaps all these
highfalutin things will start to make a
little more sense
so the the particular project
that we've been engaged in um has
is a study of deep space science and in
particular
a study that we've conducted for a
couple of years
of the cassini project
run out of nasa's jet propulsion
laboratory
now one of the things that this sort of
brings up and those of you who are
familiar with ethnographic work right
you know that
you know it comes from an
anthropological tradition and it's
basically characterized by going
somewhere
that place normally called the site
right so one of the things that's sort
of complicated for us in this project is
is even just to figure
figuring out what the site is
in one aspect the site is the jet
propulsion laboratory
of which this is an aerial photograph um
a
facility located next door to
and cold run with caltech
nestled in the foothills in pasadena in
the northern
reaches of of los angeles
a place that runs a lot of nasa
um missions it's not our research center
like
ames is it's an operations and
engineering center
um and and indeed that is the place
to which uh you know my student marissa
doing her ethnographic work
would go on a regular daily basis
now cassini happens in many places the
cassini project has run from here this
is where the operations people are this
is where that a lot of the science work
happens too
but cassini is actually a project that
involves many research groups
distributed all over the
all over the u.s and indeed all over the
world
many different scientific teams with
responsibility for different to the
scientific instruments
um uh all sort of controlling this space
this spacecraft
oh yeah the spacecraft the spacecraft
is that's another site the spacecraft
is um tumbling around in space
uh um and in particular has since 2004
been exploring the saturn system saturn
its room
its rings and some of its moons so
um it's been there as i say since 2000
since 2004 the space the whole project
in fact was um
initiated in the early 1980s
um and then designed
during the 1980s based on often actually
technology that had been developed in
the 1970s
used in previous nasa projects or
platforms that have been used in
previous nasa projects
um built in the 1990s
launched in 97 and then it got to saturn
in 2004 and at that point it's what they
call its prime
mission began which was um actually
due only to the prime mission was
it was was between 2004 and 2007
and that was the sort of first round of
exploration then they went into what
they call
xm the extended mission um which took us
up to
uh around about two around about 20 10
maybe
2011 um which since switch point they
have been
in xxm the extended extended mission you
can begin to see it's like there is
something that comes after us
just like yeah um the plan is finally
that the spacecraft will that the whole
mission will come to an end in 2017 when
they enter the death spiral
as they call it and that um spacecraft
will um
or spiral into saturn itself gathering
as much data as it does before it dies
um
so you know in one way our site is
uh is is in pasadena in the northern
regions of
los angeles in some ways our site
is somewhere between a half a billion
and a billion kilometers away depending
on the
particular astronomical configuration at
any moment
with a spacecraft that is flying a very
complicated
um path around um saturn
and and and the saturn system itself
um you know and in some ways the site is
actually
the robot the spacecraft an object
about the size of a sort of medium-sized
school bus
um to which a whole variety of um
instruments have been have been bolted
the bolting of instruments to this
spacecraft is actually a really
important part of this story as it turns
out
so the original design for cassini
was that it would have all these
different kind of scientific instruments
mounted on a thing that
looks basically like a lazy susan which
they called a scan platform that would
be out on an
arm so there'd be a gimbal at the end
and they'd be able to like point
different instruments at different kinds
of things
that was in the delightful
organizational jargon that goes along
with these things
value-engineered out of the design that
is they ran out of money
and um and so instead they bolted all
the instruments directly to the body of
the spacecraft
that saves money but creates a number of
confusions and problems for the
organization
one is that it means that uh even more
uh critically than when they were on the
scan platform
when one instrument is pointed at the
planet say
or whatever the object of astronomical
um scientific attention is just now
none of the other instruments can be
because the craft has to be pointed like
this and then it points like that right
and
all the objects all the um all the uh
instruments point in different kinds of
directions
that means that to rotate the spacecraft
and point it in a new direction
you know to make a different observation
involves rotating this whole spacecraft
um and that costs fuel and energy
these are very very precious commodities
um and so there's a lot of debate has to
happen
about what uh what the benefit is
of pointing your instrument rather than
my instrument at
this particular ring at this particular
moment when balanced against
the uh the pro the problems of spending
fuel on the rest of it
then there's all sorts of other
weirdnesses right so you know if this
instrument is pointed at the
at the um at the planet and the sun's
behind me then i have to be careful
because now the sun might have to he
might heat up that part of the
spacecraft too much and so i can't point
this thing at the planet for two
for too often so people don't want their
instrument on the side of the spacecraft
that's opposite the radiation groves and
things
all sorts of kind of nightmarish stuff
like this but this
basically this is the spacecraft is
arguably um
arguably also our site certainly the
site of everybody of everybody's
attention
now the other thing that's really
important to say about this spacecraft
is that nobody has seen it since 1997
right that's the last time it was like
locked up and you know locked up in our
in in
our rocket and bl and blasted off um
so it's kind of an interesting thing
here but we have this object of
everybody's attention
that nobody has seen for over
a decade that we can't touch that we
can't see
we can't see it through through
telescopes nothing will resolve that way
um there's a question of um of how it is
we have any kind of access to this craft
never not
us ethnographically but the space
scientists themselves and we're going to
sort of get into that
so automatically and you can hear some
of the things i've been saying
automatically in this project we have
a bunch of complicated
tensions and relationships
that need to be unpacked the first one
is the relationship between science
practice and
engineering there's scientists who after
all or do
who are doing the scientific work for
which the spacecraft was launched
which you would argue is the point of
the mission
and then there are a separate set of
people
for much of our ethnographic work on a
different floor in the building
um doing the engineering work of keeping
the spacecraft
alive making the whole thing work
getting it from point a to point b
engineering supports science but
engineering is often
in conflict with science sometimes doing
the science you want to do
endangers the spacecraft for instance
pointing an instrument in a way that
might cause another part of the
spacecraft to heat up
um making quick turns the sort of thing
that um
that that might uh endanger the
spacecraft or in something that might
endanger the life of the spacecraft that
is to run out of fuel
now would be bad and so we need to make
the fuel
last and so you get automatically this
kind of like tension between on the one
hand the engineering aspect
of keeping the thing going and making
sure it's still there tomorrow
and the scientific problem of um
getting the data that you need make
getting the observations you need doing
the science that you need
um you there's also of course
a sort of tension or an important
relationship especially when we take a
material perspective between the things
that are happening on the ground and the
things that are happening in space right
there's a spacecraft over there there's
ground systems over here here are two
pieces of technology that have to be
kept in some kind of
in some kind of alignment there's people
down here and there's no people up there
at least
as far as we know um so so you know you
might imagine that any kind of like
social material breakdown says the
material is off in space and the social
stuff is down here
that's what i'm actually going to argue
against that as we get to the end
there's another important tension that
um i'm not going to talk about so much
but it's so fascinating i want to
mention it here and it will come up a
little bit
the people for so in some
cassini is a complicated project
there are many ways in which cassini is
doing
some of the most advanced space craft
science that nasa and therefore humanity
has ever done nobody has ever flown
a spacecraft that far away this long
before we've sent spacecraft further
away and there's been missions that
lasted longer but we didn't fly them
those were ballistic orbits like voyager
you know it's like you put on a catapult
you shoot it off into space we don't
like move it around
cassini moves around right we fly
it we turn it we put we change our minds
about where it's going and it sends it
send it off in another direction
the space navigation that's happening in
cassini is by far the most advanced
complicated extended and extensive
navigation that anybody's ever done
but at the sa so it's cutting edge in
that sense at the same time
it's a dinosaur
nobody at nasa would ever run a project
this way
again remember what i said initiated in
1982 built in the
designed in the 80s built in the 90s
launched in 97
a lot of things have happened at nasa
and to nasa since 1982.
um we plan missions differently now we
do missions differently now
faster better cheaper all these things
change the kind of dynamic of
organizational work in that so we don't
do that
they don't do projects the way that
cassini is done
similarly as i said we built see or
cassini was built
um using uh platforms like you know arc
hardware architectures that had been
developed on previous missions
you know like in the 70s and in the 60s
right all their software is written in
fortran
um because that's what there was then
and so it looks and so every even at the
same time
as it's this cutting-edge project it's
this jewel in the crown it's this
amazing thing
where people live at space navigators
desperate to get onto this project
because you can do things you couldn't
do anywhere else
at the same time it's also this dinosaur
and that tension
is actually really sort of really
important to the ethnographic work as
well
okay so what i'm going to do is talk
through
um preferably without blinding myself by
stirring the protector
i want to talk through three cases
three examples three moments
um that come from our ethnographic work
that
will provide us with some perspective
for coming back to this question of
social materiality
and and asking again what might how
should we be understanding this
relationship
between the material object stuff out of
which we build systems
in the social world that lives around
them
and the first one actually um
connects to this problem this thing
about navigation the cutting edge and
amazing navigation
that that um that they're doing and at
the same time the the
ancient dinosaur nature of it
um so as i say the software that cassini
uses was all built in it's it's fortran
held together with
peril scripts um every computer science
and the sciences in the room is like
um and uh and the
fortran code is all pretty old uh these
are well
worked out well tested systems that
we've used for previous
um for previous space missions previous
that is to to to cassini so
going back pretty far in they've
developed it a lot they've tweaked it
they've done all sorts of things to it
to suit their own particular their their
own particular needs
but it's an old kind of crafty system
now in the in a new sort of more
efficient world um nasa certainly
doesn't want to be well a doesn't want
to be
running this old fortran code for every
new mission we run you know that seems
like a bad idea
and having custom software and that
custom navigation software for each
mission also seems like a bad idea
so an organizational mandate came out
to develop um cross-mission
uh navigational software a system
that you know the system was built ended
up being called called monty
um and i ought to be able to remember
what it stands for but i can't it's in
my paper
um and so monty is a new c plus plus and
python
based uh navigational system
that's intended to be the uniform
platform for all navigational systems at
all
navigation all missions at cassini that
involve navigation
and so cassidy or all missions at nasa
that involve navigation so the cassini
people naturally are included in this
charge
so the nasa the cassini people we're
tall we would like you to start running
monty
as your navigational piece of
navigational software
so they started exploring this this
possibility
and they quickly ran into um
a series of problems that basically you
know stem from the fact
that monty would give
different directions to the spacecraft
than their legacy software did
monty had a different way of doing the
math
monte was using different floating point
algorithms and velonte was using
different assumptions
and the whole result was that it was
inconsistent with the navigational
software that was already working
um the the navigators tell us they're
actually both
correct but they're sort of correct in
their own
universe of assumptions and it's very
difficult to
make this shift from a piece of software
that has successfully as far as we can
tell gotten you to saturn and flown you
around
um and you know just because the other
one is is
is written in c plus plus despite any of
these organizational mandates
the inverse problem with this the
navigational software isn't just telling
the spacecraft where to go it's the only
thing that tells us where it
is it's sort of like you know dead
reckoning on steroids here right
the spacecraft we can't see the
spacecraft the only thing we know
is we've told it to go places and it
seems to have gotten those places from
the telemetry it sends back to us
um but all the telemetry is always you
know at least 90
minutes old so it's like all you ever
know about where the spacecraft is
it's where the software says it is it's
the only kind of
object that you have to point at the
spacecraft for many for
for navigational purposes for
operational purposes is
a software produced object if you want
to know where the spacecraft is
it's only the software that can tell you
you don't actually have any direct
contact with that with that
it's not direct contact with the craft
that tells you where it is so
the idea of making this switch becomes
even more problematic it's not just
here's a new way of telling the
spacecraft where to go on a new
different set of calculations about
where the spacecraft might go
but it's even a change in the notion of
where the spacecraft
is so
these were kind of complicated problems
to um
to resolve and the the the the the
resolution actually at first was we'll
run both systems in parallel for two
months and then we'll switch over
well it's been years at this point and
nobody's switched over and
whether they actually switch overs or
you know is is un
is uncertain but um
yeah they actually called it going the
full monty that's not my pun
um but the uh
but it does this this sort of produces
this this moment of anxiety
around around the navigational software
and the idea
of the uncertainty of knowing where the
object is or even of knowing how it is
that one might know where the object is
is a really interesting one right
because that's the anxiety that's
provoked
it's like if this software is correct
and is telling us something new
then what does that mean about what we
knew before but we knew that what we
knew before was okay because
we hadn't crashed it into anything yet
so so we must be at least approximately
correct so it's like it produces this
anxiety but
how the organization might even ever
know what's going on
and the attempts they made to reconcile
the two
were confounded by the fact that the
software
carries all these levels of accretions
and complications with it
it becomes once the software you know
has lived for as long as this software
has lived
difficult if not impossible to read the
algorithm
back of the software we were talking
about algorithms earlier earlier lunch
and and the kinds of
the ways that algorithms obfuscate every
bit as much as they elucidate right you
know
um it can be difficult actually to
extract what the algorithm
is in here that's giving it different
kind of answers especially where it's
dependent
upon different kinds of for instance
double precision floating point routines
different algorithms different numerical
algorithms that the
libraries will depend on the fact that
the old software even runs on different
kinds of computers
than the new software does so it's like
i don't never mind on different versions
of the operating systems these guys are
continually in the business
of keeping old operating systems and old
computers that you've all
ignored and i've always ignored for
years going because that's where the
stuff
actually runs um you can take the slice
the core sample through
all those different kind of layers and
pull it out and say that's the algorithm
and oh look it's incompatible here with
what that what that piece of code is
doing um so
the material configurations of
uh of of software objects and hardware
objects and they're sort of
they're complicated sort of
entanglements
become you know begin to obscure
what it is the organization even knows
about
how to navigate spacecraft and where a
space where a spacecraft is
it obscures the sort of the uh the the
um the expertise that the organization
has despite the fact that there could be
no more expertise about space navigation
than there is than there is at nasa
right these guys are clearly expert
but the ways in which they're expert are
not even necessarily available to them
because of the ways they're entwined
with the software systems
the other thing that makes this matter
is another important material
consideration which is the temp
which are the temporalities of of this
stuff
one of the things one of the problems
for what
one of the aspects of the cassini
project that manifests itself in this
stuff
is that you can't stop
um so you know in the in the
organizational shifts that have happened
at nasa and they move from like large
projects to small projects the mars
rovers are often held up as sort of the
golden child of the new nasa right
that's you know we should know
everything should be like the mars
rovers and indeed that there's much to
learn
from the mars rovers and we've studied
uh janet's done a lot of work studying
the mars rover stuff
and and um and because the cassini
people certainly you know admire the
mars report but they also point out
that for the navigational problems for
the mars rover people are a lot small
um um a lot smaller because
if the mars rover doesn't know where it
is it can stop until it figures it out
and if the people if the scientists
don't know where to send it they can
stop and make a decision
you know the space the mars rover won't
go anywhere until you tell it to go and
in the meantime it'll just sit there
um you don't get to do that with cassini
there's no like putting on the brakes
and stopping and just parking in space
until you figure this stuff out
um it's continually moving um it must
continually move
and so the idea of any kind of like flag
day for switching over
it's like okay everyone stop now um just
doesn't happen right everyone
people can stop the spacecraft ain't
gonna stop
um and in fact the temporality here is
not a punctuated temporality as it is
for various other kinds of things it's a
continual ongoing
thing and the ongoingness of it the
never-endingness of it the
never-stopping of it
is actually a really important kind of
consideration
bridging them at different points
absolutely
i would say there's two things um one is
we only have one spacecraft
um actually we have two because but the
other ones the other one's still here
um uh and and and the other is
um it took us a long time to learn how
to do that and we have to build our
systems for that
and it's not clear to me that actually
the kind of technological platforms they
have on there allow for
allow for this but yeah i mean you can
see and they clearly have
like i said they're running the
navigational systems in par in parallel
it's just the switch over that's the
complicate that's the complicated part
here
um but they're but they're certainly um
they have a continual sense i'm not
talking actually so much
in today's talk about the temporalities
of this project but there well actually
somebody asked me about the temporality
of the project at the end because it's
really interesting
let's talk about it but there's this
sense continually of its ongoingness
right it's
like always you're always like you know
in the middle of
things um
okay so that was number one that going
the full monty the second of the sort of
three
things i want to talk about um they sort
of give us some kind of perspective on
these questions of social materiality
arises around a ways of accounting for
technological degradation
so spacecraft has to tumble in space and
move around to point us different kinds
of instruments at the
at the whatever the object of
astronomical and scientific attention is
at any given moment
it has two ways of doing that you can
fire like you know
rockets and like you know move that way
um but the
spacecraft all can also sort of rotate
on its own axis
and it does this by having a set of what
they call reaction wheels which are
wheels you can sort of spin up
and you know by the conservation of
angular momentum you can
unite the spacecraft will will rotate um
in the
in the in the opposite direction and so
if you have a series of wheels mounted
on different axes you can sort of rotate
the spacecraft
without using up quite so much of the
fuel as you would if you were
if you were using the using the engines
so that's how a spacecraft was launched
with a series of wheels all working
just fine um and af but after a while
they began to notice
that the wheels weren't behaving
exactly to spec one of the wheels was
breaking down
now the actual process of interpreting
what the wheels do is really complicated
because you also actually used
it was dragging but drag is actually one
of the ways that they do gravitational
measurements as they get close things
and
actually at some points you deliberately
fly the spacecraft through the outer
atmosphere
of some of some bodies in order to sit
in or and use the drag to assess
what the um the density of that
atmosphere is and so forth but
nonetheless they were because they were
beginning to recognize that they weren't
getting the performance that they
expected and
the wheels were degrading and eventually
actually one of the wheels got got
turned off and they sort of put in a put
in a backup
but it created this um tension within
the project where now
we they sort of went oh we need to be
paying attention to the up to the to the
performance of the reaction wheels
as a way of understanding what the
spacecraft's doing and what things are
doable what things we can actually
support
so they built a piece of software called
orbot the
reaction wheel bias optimization tool
that one i remember
and arbot is a mathematical model
of the behavior of the wheels that
allows them to
um evaluate potential movements of the
spacecraft pointing arrangements of the
spacecraft observations the spacecraft's
going to make
in terms of the reaction the impact upon
the reaction wheels whether it's going
to take the reaction wheels into
dangerous frequency bands that are sort
of problematic and cause the reaction
goes to degrade
faster or whether this is um a safe
maneuver
what they often call rbot friendly a
design
that's going to like work with a work
with the with the
reaction wheels but there's a couple of
problems
so the first is
our bot is kind of a slow piece of
software it just i mean there's a lot to
figure out here
and it takes a long time it takes a kind
of more more than it takes a long time
it takes an unpredictable amount of time
i can tell you
um somebody who lives in los angeles any
studies that are ever done of like
traffic and the things that cause stress
on your commute are not about how long
your commute is it's about how
predictable your commute is
the problem with arbonne the thing that
causes organizational stress is not that
it takes a long time to run but that
nobody quite knows how long it's going
to take to run
and nobody quite knows what it is that
it's going to say we know the algorithm
we know the math
but we don't know it nobody's got a sort
of intuitive understanding of it at
least not on the science side the
engineers have a better understanding of
it but but from the science side all
they know
is that once upon a time they could say
this is the
instrument pointing that i need to do
and go do it and the engineers would say
okay here's your data
and now they say here's the instrument
pointing that i need to do and the
engineers say no we're not going to do
that that's not friendly to the wheels
but that they might say that at an
unpredictable moment
um so the um
inscrutability of our bot
at the same time as it's the
absoluteness of its decisions or its
statements
is sort of a problem um and so
the organization had to sort of switch
things around
in order to try to get to a point where
they could do
science in a way that would not bring it
into conflict
with with with with engineering the
scientists wanted
a set of guidelines saying what kinds of
things are arbor friendly and what kinds
of things are not but they
are what doesn't work that way you can't
say you can point it this way and you
can find it that way and it's going to
be
okay because it's all about how you get
from over here to over there and it
depends on where the spacecraft is and
again the gravitational forces
that impinge upon it at different
different kind of moments
um and so nobody can quite get
to what the um what are bot friendly is
the software the algorithm has inserted
itself into the organizational planning
process
and in fact the organization had to
completely change its scientific
planning process
to place our bot assessment early on
because now there was there was a moment
of bizarre breakdown where the engineers
said to the scientists well you need to
so that we can figure out which of these
things we're going to be able to do you
need to give us the science
observations in you know on some kind of
priority order
and the scientists are like are you guys
kidding everything on here is a priority
that's why it's on the list we spent six
months
fighting with each other figuring out
what things we were going to put on the
list
the result of that is is like it's just
everything's a high priority
um so so the the the organization
actually had to respond by also making
all sorts of changes
in order to incorporate our bot into
what they're doing now this is an
interesting thing they're not really in
some ways record incorporating the
reaction wheels into what they're doing
they're incorporating our bot into what
they're doing our bot is a piece of
software that was after all built
without if after the wheels that it
talks about we're already millions of
miles away right you know nobody's seen
the wheel
since we built our bot we actually only
have a you know an in principle
understanding that what arbot says
is actually what's going on with the
wheels because we built the software
afterwards
um so it's kind of complicated how we
incorporate this thing so that then
takes me to the second point which is
this one about sort of
where's the material here
if we talk about social material we say
the social organization has responded in
some ways it's responded to material
constraints
but you could argue that the material
constraints to which it's responding are
not the degradation of the wheels but
rather
the operation of a piece of software on
a particular computer
yeah that is if this is something that
actually the organization could
respond to differently because i can put
more memory into my computer
and have it you know come up with an
answer faster that's a kind of
interestingly alternative
material constraint here the materiality
that's grounding their practice is not
simply the materiality of a school bus
sized object
tumbling around in space it's the
materiality of the ground systems the
materiality of the computers the fact
that
software takes a while to run and that
we don't necessarily know how long
that takes okay
skip on to the third um
five past two is that what you said just
one question okay good
um the third example is
is granted a piece of software called
the tour atlas um
there is it will be no surprise to you a
lot
a lot of software going on in this
system
and some software is absolutely mission
critical you know the kind of software
which you know
if this software was to go wrong a
spacecraft filled with
radioactive fuel would explode in orbit
and rain the fuel down on
the voters of some potential
congressional district so we can't have
that happen obviously
um and you know so uh some software is
like important but less critical and so
forth so that
and actually nasa has this whole set of
categories category a category b
category c
depending on the criticality of the
software and the process by which it
will be developed modified and changed
there is also a term people use category
d
which refers to uncategorized software
right this residual category
all the other stuff the category d
software is like the kind of little
things that you build for yourselves
your
your python programs and your perl
scripts and your random little bits of
wizardry that hack together the
different pieces of your life and make
it possible
for you to actually get anything done
the tour atlas is is a piece of category
d software
so the tour atlas is this is this
set of scripts that generates html pages
that describe
things about how um where the spacecraft
has been in the past and how certain
kinds of
arrangements navigational and pointing
arrangements were achieved
it takes a slice through lots of
databases
um and pulling information from all
sorts of different kinds of places
in order to just help people to uh
to get their work done more easily
by reusing knowledge from the history of
the from the history of the mission
um the tour atlas was a set of scripts
put together by a guy
or called him jim ah and j and the thing
is that jim was building this software
pretty much for his own benefit
but pretty soon everybody got the idea
that it was there people would go
you know you would know that if you
could save yourself some time
by going and getting work sitting down
at jim's desk with jim and having jim
take you through whether the particular
kind of thing you've done you're wanting
to do
is something we've ever done before how
is the organization able to do this well
here's here's it here's it's here's it's
history
um it's just
you know and this this is partly because
the planning process for these things is
so long
so as i told you all the different spit
all the different scientists have to
like
hash out for amongst themselves how it
is they're going to get their
instruments to point it in the places
the ways they want
and and may get their observations to
get their science
and there's all sorts of competition
between different scientists about you
know to do this
and so there's a you know that's one
complicated process of like you know
i need this you know a bunch of planets
time on this next pass no
no you haven't published enough journal
papers lately so clearly your stuff
isn't generating enough science
um so you know and and you don't want to
go through all that process
and then get to the end and discover you
can't do it right
the spacecraft can't be pointed in that
direction so this is a way to have a
sort of responsive tool
that you can be using early in the
planning process to figure out we know
this works because we know we did it
before and this gave me
you know a scan pattern that works for
the ultraviolet spectrometer whatever it
is
um but then jim
left um because nasa has a matrix model
matrix organization and
um and and uh and so people often move
around inside the organization different
sort of different missions
um and and the tour atlas sort of fell
apart
and so then some people were put on the
job the rather
unusual job of like of maintaining
category d software right which is meant
to be inherently unmaintained
um in order to sort of make things work
and they managed to put it back together
again in some ways
but but you know then they never sort of
operated quite the way
that it ever did before because jim
wasn't just the programmer after all he
was
the person he was the guy who knew how
to make this work and this wasn't
actually about
um using gym software this was about
working with jim
it was always about working with jim it
was jim who could
um could steer you through the
archive he knew how to navigate the
archive
in terms that the tour atlas provided
and the organization i mean it hasn't
lost knowledge in the sense that
all the databases that say where they've
been and how they got there and what
they did when they got there
are still there um and arbot still or
i'm sorry the tour atlas still works as
a way to extra
now there's a way to extract stuff
and yet the way in which it's going to
be entwined into a sort of informal
planning process has sort of broken down
because it ended up sort of um relying
so much on
on on gym um so the software evolves
it is after all and and it evolves as a
mode of figuring right as a mode of
figuration the software
now gives because the cassini team
members a new way to represent
sea to figure um the the spacecraft's
own movements
its history of movements is potential
movements its past
its potential futures um
the software evolves the organization
evolves but they don't necessarily
evolve together and in lockstep and the
the
the issue in particular here is that um
we can maintain the software we can
maintain the code
but what they actually find more
problematic is maintaining the set of
relations
around the code that actually make it
work as i say
the issue with making the tour outlets
work is not making the code work
using the tour atlas was not running a
piece of software using the tour atlas
is sitting with jim um and
and so the tour atlas was always and
only
an adjunct to a series of things that
jim was doing
even as it was a sort of database
browser right
so database browser only works if you
know how to
how to look through it
okay so so three cases
uh monty r bot and the tour atlas
three pieces of software um
that are deeply entwined into sort of
organizational life and scientific
practice three modes
of figuring um
three ways of seeing the
spacecraft seeing the mission producing
a representation of it
in the case of monty really like
literally in figures numbers digits um
in the case of our bot in terms of like
it's yes or no answer is about the
danger to the spacecraft and the
terrorism
for for the tour atlas ways of figuring
particular moments of history and
potential and potential
potential futures um each of which
speak to questions of socio-materiality
by
giving us points of purchase on the
relationship between social forms and
material forms
um so so what would this tell us about
the ways that people have tried to
analyze social materiality
as or employ social materiality as a way
of
um as a way of analyzing organizational
needs in the relationship to of
societies to
social structures to to technology
well well the first one
is is sort of
you know the first kind of
socio-material uh
uh conception is one of like the social
and the material is separate
yeah and then that the analysis that we
want to understand
is one that speaks to the relationality
between them right speaks to how these
two go together
there's the social world there's the
material world
and social materiality is about how do
we how do we stitch these
stitch these together
you would think that a separation kind
of approach to socio-materiality would
work really well here
after all we have a project which has
arguably
two sites which are approximately a
billion kilometers apart
pretty separate so a separation argument
kind of ought to be
useful here but we just don't you know
we don't find that separation
working after all arguably what people
interact with is not
the spacecraft what they interact with
is all sorts of stuff in the ground
systems
which are apparently telling a story
about where a spacecraft might be
but you know it might have been captured
by the martians and they could be
beaming us
all by all sorts of weird telemetry
right um they
uh the the the notion of looking for
points of separation
as a way of understanding the
relationship between a world that is
purely social here and a world that is
purely material there
that somehow have some kind of um link
that just that that just doesn't seem to
work
very well in this case even in fact if
we don't draw the dividing line
at you know the outer planets
um even if we even we look for other
other kinds of separations
um there's a there's a much more
complicated
tangle um tangle at work here
the second kind of approach that a lot
of people have taken in the
in the socio-materiality literature
is a sort of um a sort of symmetry
approach
which says social and material are two
aspects of the kind of sort of like
contemporary organizational systems
contemporary social systems
that sort of mirror each other in the
ways in which
they push on um
the push on the world uh they
sort of constitute they both constitute
the world
um they both bring the world into
particular kinds of arrangements
um and they do so in sort of roughly
equal
symmetric you know ways they do so in
lockstep the social and the material
are both continually making things that
making things
um uh the way they are
um that said you know that's a i like
that a little better than the separation
argument
um but we don't find that working
terribly well analytically for us in
this data either
because in fact in our situation what we
seem to
have i mean the symmetry argument again
i remember at the beginning i was seeing
these things all sort of refigure
around where do you locate the agency
the symmetry argument says you locate it
um equally continually in both of the in
both of these domains
but we sort of find that kind of rocking
back and forth here
sometimes the stuff that's going on
under the ground is what matters the
most sometimes the stuff that's going on
in the organization sometimes it's the
stuff that
the the the materiality of the computer
systems
sometimes there are these interventions
from the saturn system where
broken down or degrading
wheels or bad telemetry suddenly forces
a reorganization of both technical and
social material practice on the practice
on the ground and so forth so
so a symmetry arm doesn't seem to work
because it's more of a sort of tacking
back and forth
that we're finding that we're finding at
work
and then finally um the the
you know this this sort of shaping
argument
is sort of the third of the the ways in
which again many people have tackled the
social material
which is primarily that sort of you know
it's still harkening back to the social
constructionist the idea that places
us humans social systems as the primary
force in shaping material realities we
shape material realities
and then and we use them as tools to con
to create
particular kinds of arrangements for
tools to create particular kinds of um
um
outcomes that still sort of places us at
the center um that one just to sort of
you know is
we don't see this kind of
unidirectionality as i said we've got
this sort of attacking tacking back and
forth
so by placing an emphasis
i sort of began with and the the paper
in which this talk is based sort of
really sort of argues instead
for a kind of understanding this in
terms of
reconfiguration right figuring the
figural practices by which particular
kinds of
models of reality are produced
doing so configuring doing that figuring
in a way that is deeply connected to
what they describe
because you know uh you know you've got
you can't be decoupled from that
um and reconfiguring that is the idea
that this has to be done
again and again and again and again that
like the spacecraft tumbling through
ongoingly through space
you never stop it's always partial it's
always it's always incomplete
and so we have this sort of asymmetric
dynamic
shifting set of relations between those
things that we can think of as material
perhaps and those things that we can
think of as social
um or the or the social aspects of the
whole and the return
relational aspects of the whole um cena
sort of projections rather than
um rather than a sort of this
sort of simpler separation symmetry or
or shaping kind of analysis
the idea here is to pay attention to
the representational practices that
technologies provide us with to think
about the technologies that we're used
to thinking about as things that do
stuff
through our control or whatever in the
world but thinking about them also
as things that present the world to us
that craft a representation of it and
give it to us
in such a way that it makes certain
kinds of opportunities for action
manifest um and thinking i think about
these kind of technologies in
figural representational ways and
understanding the material constraints
upon those kinds of representations
gives us a different route into thinking
what about organizations and what they
do here
um i am not going to talk this is part
of a larger project
on the materialities of information and
thinking about the material constraints
around information itself not
information infrastructures
and not just the fact that servers cost
money and they have to sit in rooms and
they use electricity and they move
like hot air from one place to another
and the rest of it but thinking about
how
information itself has
um material properties granularity
temporality
um malleability and so forth
that's a larger project um that i would
have talked out if i hadn't already
talked for so long
so i will not talk more about that um
but
um maybe i'll come back and talk about
another time
all right um i think we still have some
time to take questions
thank you speaker
okay paul can you pull back out from
from the mars
work and doing the cd project and
articulate for those who might be
unfamiliar with the approach that you're
using
the value of this work in other social
material contexts
why should someone who doesn't care
about cassini but does care about
computation
information systems communication
processes written large
care about how we how about
reconfiguration in the manner that
you've described
um well i mean i think the first thing
is just to try to
uh to focus
on the figural in in in most of this
stuff
um which i think often goes away we
think about you know we sort of
we recognize that what we're using in
most in most
digital systems are representations of
some sort and yet the ways that they get
made effective
often sort of i think then blinds us to
their figural properties
um especially over time and so the other
part is actually i think that um
the dynamics of this and the temporal
and the temporal dynamics of it so the
fact this is sort of always ongoing
becomes really really important um i was
talking uh to
some of the guys here earlier today
about some work i've been doing around
through the materialities of databases
and one of the important things there is
to sort of recognize the database as a
historically maturing form
in which everyone the kinds of things
that databases did yesterday inform us
but the kinds of things that databases
might do tomorrow and so that figural
coupling
to the world that is both sort of
productive of particular kinds of
experience as well as somehow you know
um speaking back to you about about the
world um are really
important i think that changes the way
that um a lot of the ter a lot of the
um argumentation around social
materialities particularly in
organizational studies
um happens and i think it's um much much
broader than simply that simply
the cassini stuff but because we do
frequently have this
um this idea of uh that there are the
running
this idea of the for instance a
separation between
um between individually and separately
constituted domains of social and
material that somehow
you know oh yeah i have to build a
conceptual bridge there but they
that you know puts them together but
keeps them apart at the same time
is is is i think what we're trying to
what we're trying to do so cassini
turns out to be a useful place to do
that because of some of the um
separations that it has
uh but i think that i think the point
speak much more broadly to the way that
that
the notions of the social and the
material are invoked as that sort of
analytic frame
so as perhaps another connection here
you're sort of making a plato's cave
argument where you know we can't
actually see the spacecraft but we can
sort of see some
some shadows of it and yeah i i made a
connection earlier to
the web and imagine now your facebook
you can move all of these
these code wheels and all you see are
data later about people clicked this
many more things they liked this many
more things they
they were doing this they were trending
people and you have this sort of
indirection and what ends up happening
is that
you know the sociology organization is
still trying to manage
this these indirect data about how
people are
acting and i wonder if you think that's
actually a similar kind of
uh set of entanglements that's going on
is it different well i mean certainly
you see and we see
in many of the cases of the database um
and and and
working working with digital traces
um this question of am i working with
the data or am i working with what it is
that data represents right am i reaching
through the data or is the data
is the data my my object um
and i do think again sort of going to
what i was saying to fred as well that
the
it's it's actually often the temporal
dynamics that pull this stuff back
together
because because you know what makes the
data an effective proxy for certain
kinds of activity is the fact that it's
responsive in the right ways right
that it maintains its identity over uh
uh maintains its identity
over over time um
i what i want to keep um a focus of
attention on
and this absolutely goes to like all the
sort of big data arguments as well the
rest of it is that sort of mediating
role
of algorithms as sort of active objects
that you know are producing
certain kinds of uh certain kinds of
data for that for the you know for
particular purposes
um and and that we often i think forget
about that sort of active
role i mean this goes against things
we're chatting about earlier it's like
this
this relationship between algorithms and
data has in many ways become
um really quite problematic and you know
lately as
that as the dentistries become almost
like themselves sort of live
objects that um that confound
our ability to understand what the
algorithms even even do right so you get
to that sort of thing like these guys
had with their with their navigational
software where you can
you can't read the algorithm back off
and even if you could it wouldn't really
tell you very much
which is that that's the complicated
thing so i think
trying to find what the right sort of
figure ground shift is that allows us to
keep both of those in view at the same
time
um is is really important and i think
that is something that would tie
most of those sort of data practices to
the kinds of things that these guys are
doing too
um so anything that kind of
you think about building something and
then 15 years down the road
yeah is there turnover are there people
that believe like and how
and do the new people understand what
the older people did
how do you pass that wisdom along that's
a so that's a
great question um there is
lots of turnover and lots of churn and
the kind of turnover and the kind of
turn there is
turns out to be fascinating so
this so they happen differently on the
science science side and the um
and the engineering side in this
particular part of the project i've been
talking about today we were mainly
studying the engineering side on the
science
side you know pis die
and they get replaced by their own
graduate students and things like that
you know there's
there's a certain kind of like academic
churn on that side i'm not going to
think too much about that
um on the engineering side people
certainly move around the matrix
organization kind of like forces that
people move into this project
navigators for instance move into this
project because they want to do the kind
of like cool navigation stuff
um people sort of people certainly cycle
around a good deal
um the one of the things that is really
fascinating and actually marissa is
trying to write about this just now
on the engineering side this project has
become the province
of a number of very senior um
older women the men
all moved on to hipper
cooler more powerful projects
and many of the senior engineering women
speak about this as a long-term
investment a duty of care
they owe to the spacecraft and often the
last mission they're going to do so the
woman who runs the engineering side now
is actually the only person in the whole
project who's ever touched the
spacecraft
because she was part of um alto assembly
something and testing right the sort of
assembly launch and testing operations
the part would put the spacecraft
together and she actually frequently
draws on that knowledge like no no
that's not where that wire runs that
wire actually goes over here because i
remember
and all those kinds of things um but
actually the gender issues
associated with how people have moved
into and out of this project is a
fascinating
thing all to itself that's a different i
mean mercer could get a second phd a
second phd out of that
um but yeah there's a real question
about what it means to for instance move
into a project that
you're primarily written in fortune how
many people here you know
how are your fortran skills brushing up
on that
um um you know are there yeah yes
um i remember talking to people at
cambridge university whose intro classes
at that time were basic standard ml and
cobol and like what are you trying to do
to these people
like so um so it's you know it's really
kind of intriguing to sort of think
about what how people do sort of like
you know manage that
manage those those skill sets especially
and they have to work in a market
kind of model where they're shopping
their you know the way to make progress
in the organization is not to stay with
cassini
until the death spiral the way to make
progress in the organization is to pick
up some skills here and then move
somewhere else so the organization kind
of forces them into that sort of turn
mode but it has played out differently
in science and engineering and it's
played out differently for people at
different levels of seniority and it's
played out really differently across
gender divides in ways that i find i
find fascinating